this video was brought to you by
brilliant hi welcome to another episode
of Cold Fusion you've been working hard
all day and just arrive home totally
exhausted just when you sink into the
couch you receive a text from your wife
who's still at work she's excited about
plans for Valentine's Day tonight you
panic as you completely forgot you pick
up your iPhone and ask Siri to directly
plan a date night that starts at 6:00
p.m. and finishes at 12:00 Siri
recommends a great Lookout spot to watch
the Sunset It Books your wife's favorite
restaurant and then recommends an art
gallery nearby
afterwards of course as we all know this
scenario is purely fictional there's no
way Siri could execute such a series of
tasks automatically but what if it could
with today's generative AI breakthroughs
this scenario is technically possible in
fact in the last episode we saw how a
little orange device called the rabbit
R1 set out to do just that the idea goes
ask ask the rabbit what you want and it
will interface with your apps to
complete the task on your behalf
essentially it's a voice first AI
powered device as I highlighted in the
second part of that episode there's a
fatal flaw with the rabbit all of this
functionality could just be integrated
into a phone although nothing like the
rabbit's functionality exists yet in a
smartphone it will be coming soon enough
we've seen Google integrate AI into
their pixel phones and Samsung do the
same with the introduction of the Galaxy
s24 so the question has to be asked
where is Apple in all of this although
Siri is next to useless today as you
might have guessed apple is secretly
cooking something up in the background
in this episode we'll take a look at
what they've been up to and I'll explain
exactly why Siri sucks there's actually
an internal staff Revolt in the Siri
department so it's a juicier story than
you
[Music]
think you are watching cold fusion
TV Microsoft and Google have been
shouting the loudest about AI but Apple
has been quiet the California company
barely mentioned AI in any of their
product launchers but behind the scenes
they've actually bought the most AI
companies of all since 2017 Apple has
bought 21 AI startups while Microsoft
has bought 12 meta 11 and Google SL
alphabet just eight Apple's been
spending about $1 billion in AI Ventures
while remaining silent from self-driving
technology to voice design music
generation and image recognition these
are just some of the Specialties of
these AI companies that Apple's been
purchasing there may even be more behind
the scenes this silence is typical
behavior from Apple they move last but
move decisively they didn't invent the
computer mouse graphical interface
smartphone tablet or Smartwatch but they
revolutionized all of these categories
by doing it better than was done
before so what do we know about Apple's
AI effort in August of 2023 Tim Cook
revealed that apple had been researching
generative AI for years on a call with
investors he said quote we tend to
announce things as they come to Market
and that's our Mo and I'd like to stick
to that end
quote while everyone was losing their
minds over chat gbt Apple had been
tinkering with similar Concepts way
before its release since 2020 the
company assembled a foundational models
team the goal was to develop
conversational AI similar to that of
chat GPT but with a focus on UND device
machine learning and privacy the team
consists of 16 people including former
Google engineers and the head of the
team John Jan Andrea was previously head
of machine intelligence research and
search at Google Bloomberg reported in
mid 2023 that Apple has created a large
language model called Ajax GPT it's
similar to chat GPT or Google's Lambda
but is said to outperform GPT 3.5
there's even chatter about Apple working
on an AI powered chatbot dubbed Apple
GPT that's based on Ajax although
there's a rumored release date of mid
2024 right now it's still tightly
controlled within the
company Apple has also quietly released
Frameworks and model libraries designed
to run on its chipsets and may even
bring a generative AI apps to MacBooks
according to the information multiple
teams are working on various AI projects
within Apple so it's quite evident that
there's been a lot of activity from
Apple on AI behind the scenes so what is
going to be the best use of it well
Siri Siri itself was an Apple
acquisition back in 2010 just one year
later the system was incorporated into
the iPhone and it's been frustrating
users ever since it's ironic because
back then Apple was way ahead of the
pack when it came to voice assistance
but now well I don't need to say much
more we'll talk about how Apple aims to
improve Siri but first what is the deal
with Siri why does it leave so much to
be desired in April 2023 a bombshell
report came to light that explained
everything you see over the past 5 years
or so the Siri team within Apple has
devolved into a dumpster fire employees
and management would bitterly argue
about the direction of the assistant and
in the end no meaningful progress was
made here's a summary of all the
problems within the Siri team Siri
Engineers weren't given tools to see how
many users were using Siri and how often
they were using it Engineers would beg
for more data to improve Siri but
leadership wouldn't hear any of it Apple
Executives wanted to keep future
developments of Siri on device having no
network connection to a massive AI model
run on a server put Apple's efforts at a
disadvantage Apple Executives dismissed
back and forth responses to Siri because
it would be too difficult to control Tim
Cook himself as well as other senior
Executives refused to have thei
responses AI generated instead they
opted for a team of 20 writers to come
up with canned pre-written responses I
guess that explains a lot Apple's
obsession with strict control over the
user experience is at direct odds with
the freedoms of generative AI
responses in 2019 Apple's design team
repeatedly rejected a feature where
users could report a concern or issue
with a Siri answer the machine learning
Engineers were essentially working blind
and couldn't improve the system so what
was the reasoning for this decision
upper management wanted Siri to appear
quote all knowing eventually
frustrations began building and
employees began to leave Apple because
they were too slow to make decisions
about Ai and were just scared of making
mistakes Tim Cook personally pleaded for
disgruntled Engineers to stay at the
company but they would eventually leave
to work on large language models at
Google there was even an attempt to
rebuild Siri from the ground up with a
project called Blackbird the project
aimed to make Siri faster lighter and
more modular however it was axed by two
senior leaders on the Siri team who
championed their own project Siri X this
only focused on moving series processing
to on device and the rest of the
Blackbird project was abandoned and just
when he thought things couldn't get any
worse the group working on Apple's mixed
reality headset The Vision Pro were
reportedly so unimpressed with Siri's
capabilities that they considered
creating their own voice system and
that's how you know it's bad
so all of these issues explain why Siri
isn't doing too hot and it's not for a
lack of trying there was just too much
friction within the team and to add
insult to injury it seems that Siri is
only getting more dull one of its most
common phrases today is sorry I don't
understand or here are some results I
found on the web so what is the future
of Siri then let's move on to how Apple
can turn things around before we
continue I just want to give a quick
shout out to today's sponsor brilliant
Apple getting into the AI space
certainly is interesting but have you
ever thought how does AI work anyway
well now there's a fun and easy way to
learn about that and other stem subjects
with brilliant brilliant's course on
artificial neural networks is perfect
for that I've used it to brush up on
some background context when making
episodes on AI all the way back in 2020
when we were talking about gpt3 before
it blew up in the media 2 years later
brilliant has interactive stem courses
in anything from maths to computer
science and general science whether you
just want to brush up on learning or
need a refresher for your career
brilliant has you covered you can get
started free for 30 days and the first
200 people to sign up get 20% off an
annual plan by visiting the URL
brilliant.org
coldfusion thank you now back to the
episode according to Mark German's power
on newsletter the upcoming iOS 18 might
introduce significant updates to the
iPhone according to German Apple's
generative AI technology could
significantly improve Siri but that's
not all as per a report by the
information Apple plans to use large
language models to make Siri smarter so
ideally Siri should be able to perform
complex task from a simple voice command
if this becomes a reality it would be a
significant Leap Forward for Siri but it
also means that the rabbit r1's days are
numbered even sooner than I first
predicted even the AI companies
purchased by Apple on their shopping
spree indicate a big Siri push so far we
know that Apple bought inductive to
improve sir's data voices to help Siri
understand natural language and pool
string to make Siri features easier to
implement for iOS developers after the
conflicts within the Siri team these
advancements could be a welcome change
for apple and Siri users worldwide
speaking of which one incredible
advantage that Apple has over its
competitors is that they already have
devices in the hands of over a billion
users with that in mind Apple can
finally leverage on device or Edge AI
unlike cloud computing for large
language models Edge AI runs on the
device eliminating the need for cloud
servers or an internet connection this
can offer faster more secure and more
reliable performance for AI Computing
Apple has splashed $200 million to
acquire xnor AI this was to improve its
on device processing
capabilities as we know Apple now has
arm-based chips with custom neural
processing units built for their laptops
watches phones and tablets being in
complete control of both hardware and
software components gives a tighter
integration and efficiency than the
competition it's a great position for
Apple to be in for on device AI systems
this aligns with the Visionary and
Pioneer in computer science Alan K's
philosophy he once said quote people who
are serious about software should make
their own
Hardware now on device large language
models have been done before but they
perform sluggishly and aren't ready for
the prime time though Apple researchers
may have cracked the code code they've
managed to squeeze a large language
model into a Macbook but not only this
it runs 4 to 25 times faster than
standard models depending on if it's GPU
or CPU focused the Apple researchers
released a paper on it they managed to
do this by using a few clever techniques
including storing the model in the
device's flash memory instead of ram the
Apple researchers also claim that they
can run models that are two times larger
than the computer's physical memory it
sounds impossible but I'll leave a link
to the paper below so you can see how
they did
[Music]
it Siri has been stagnant function-wise
for many years and this could be a major
breakthrough uh that provide much better
iOS or um across Apple device user
experience uh our view is that if you
have a tool like open AI uh that's
hardly a point of differentiation uh in
a couple years everyone will have a its
own large lendage model uh similar to
chbt so Apple's advantage is very unique
comparing to other model Builders they
have devices in the consumer's hands a
billion plus consumers and once they
have features embedded in iOS for
example you have that feature pushed out
to billions of devices and uh you know
well over hundreds of millions users
overnight and that's is a market access
Advantage no one else has going behind
the scenes it's clear that apple is not
sleeping but this is the furthest behind
I've seen them in living memory AI does
move fast so it'll be interesting to see
how they deal with that along with the
internal conflicts within their Siri
department so what do you think is Apple
too late or do you think they'll
surprise everyone with a polished take
on AI could their version of AI be
smarter and faster let me know what you
think in the comment section below
anyway that's about it from me if you
want to see anything on science
technology or business feel free to
subscribe to Cold Fusion my name is
deogo and you've been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next episode cheers guys have a good
[Music]
one cold fusion it's new
thinking